when you actually believe in the value
you're providing selling promoting
giving for free when you believe it all
clicks the reason people don't do is
because they don't believe they odd
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
[Music]
137 p.m. is just looking at men's
culture 15 to 55 the mindset the grind
the hustle health and wellness fashion
music sports culture entrepreneurship
mindset positivity I'm so [ __ ] fired
up about 137 PM actually you know what
I'm gonna actually ask for a favor it
matters a lot to me I think we're it's
gonna be a big deal as you can imagine
and it would mean a lot to me if you
guys could share 137 p.m. today
I just posted on Twitter the big article
if you can go and retweet that that
would mean the world to me or if you
could post the URL or pass on the site
it would mean so much to me this is
something we've been working on for a
year
the 137 Instagram right now has a ton of
cool [ __ ] on it on Instagram it's one
it's the word one spend about 3 7 p.m.
all right guys I got to go into this
event actually this will be fun
so these peeps really won because they
they won the breakfast alright this is
the breakfast crew
Breakfast Club good to see you
let's see - oh good nice to meet you hey
hurry how are you pleasure
hi how are you how are things sit sit
sit
Congrats guys thank you guys won the you
won the game alright Instagram I'm out
of here this is the crew that wouldn't
you got you guys won the ten books the
things like the things that motivate me
motivated me before
kind of doing motivate you know of
course this December something something
you struggled with and do you have any
advice well I don't think it's a
struggle I think it's an accomplishment
for if you're in a place where you're
motivated by self you know me people
live 88 years of their lives motivated
by money and never get away from it
because they never achieved the money
right interesting
you know many people are motivated by
the chase of Fame for ninety two years
of their life and never stopped because
they never got famous like like it this
is such a fun this is what this is about
that is such a subtle terminology shift
you've been looking at it as a negative
it's a massive it's a it's a massive
absolutely yeah like it's like oh let me
let I apologize but I want to frame it
for you like I'm secretly worried that
I'm going to get to a place where I'm
not gonna care anything about business
and it's the love of my life but I can
like feel it already I'm like you know
55 to 75 is gonna be some run when you
actually believe in the value you're
providing selling promoting giving for
free when you believe it all clicks the
reason people don't do is because they
don't believe they are either or
insecure and structured that way or they
deep down know they're doing it for the
money
how many people like did things for me
with expectation
I'll come and most of the times I'll say
no because I don't want to do that but
once a lot I say yes mainly to stick it
to them and teach them a life lesson
which is don't come at me and be like I
want to do this awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought 10,000
books and did this thing was because
what you really wanted was my [ __ ]
face on your website cosign in your
[ __ ] business well then you should
have told me because then we get ahead a
transaction I might want to sneak in
Mirabelle
hold on nope Hana Roth call my friend
wish him and his son good luck this
weekend I'm so glad you caught all of
that my world works I think you know
know one thing and I'm you calling Todd
Ruth I love it I love doing surprise and
delight from social media follow me on
Twitter
[Music]
Todd this is Gary Vaynerchuk life is
good man I want him to take a minute and
wish you guys luck in the tournament
this weekend we really appreciate it man
are you guys gonna win it yeah yeah
who's that what's your name man Carter
Carter it's a real pleasure bro I hope
you guys so your folk your positive
Carter you [ __ ] got this this is like
unlock you're gonna win it yeah oh
really where are you with the podcast
how often more Facebook
I'm more on Israel do what I do
you can literally leave right now just
do everything I'm doing all of it
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter Email texts
[ __ ] just you know how I say like
watch what I'm doing not what I'm saying
just do everything I'm doing it'll work
the the bigger part that you have to do
that's the whites kradic that's the
right thing what you fill it with is
gonna be the variability for success I'm
giving you the right cup I got good good
what I tell people to do is get the
leverage you know let them go to your
Instagram and see 10,000 people there in
an active community let them hear that
you're selling out every time you have a
new thing then they're gonna come to you
the thing I do extremely well all the
fancy people every fancy person you've
ever seen me with anyone
Tony the rock anyone anyone I've never
reached out to them let everything come
to you all of it thanks guys I gotta run
what's what when people talk to me about
this space I'm like you've got to
understand like this is just a talent
game because no matter how much you
network with me or Ferris or [ __ ]
whatever right if you're not good on
stage then you're not good on stage
right and you've all the advantages like
life is a funny game isn't it yeah you
know what I mean like you're gonna have
all the advantages cuz your story you're
like on third base now I just have to
deliver on stage everything else will
work out and if you're producing content
and building awareness and Jay being
with people and building up that brain
association the number one thing I would
tell you is just make sure you're
patient then clearly the here's where
you [ __ ] up in your impatience you build
the wrong relationships with the people
that you need to have relationships with
the amount of people that no longer have
a relationship with me because they were
just hungry for money in the short term
get bored or weren't looking to have a
relationship they were just looking a
siphon from me game over yeah got it
yeah so as long as you deploy look look
how good your guy the collective five
years five of you are like younger than
me like you got time yeah yeah so we're
all under those here
speak for us for and for me growing up
you know I was bullied as a little I was
411 depression yeah yeah yeah mom
gassing up too but what I really love is
your underdog mentality yeah how do you
complete that the momentum is going and
everything else you know what's funny
I don't know meaning it just has not
been able to leave me but I'm not so
sold I think the biggest thing and I
don't know you know when I say I don't
know here's what I can tell you when
people gas me the [ __ ] up I don't hear
it yeah and that was a watch like when
[ __ ] Prince dies in 24 hours nobody
gave a [ __ ] ever again or Maya Angelou
or things of that nature I'm like okay
let's like you know let's not get too
crazy here like no matter how much
impact you're gonna have like you'll
have your if you're a killer you'll have
a day a day and a half of the internet
like giving you love or whatever the
Internet is of the time and then they'll
be all back to like right like Anthony
Bourdain is not coming at anybody's
mouth anymore so you get your time he
I've said you know I was really
impressed he'd really affected a lot of
people that was a real right but also
it's timing like if there's a war
breaking out or an economy collapses and
you happen to die at that minute or like
a royal wedding like you get washed out
so like for me it's kind of like yeah
it's it's a it's humility it underdog
mentality matures into a humility that's
important yeah can you get Alex I know
I'm gonna be [ __ ] late for this
meeting I want to spend more time with
you guys cuz you know one thing I play
on is intuition I really do
the reason I'm pushing you on the other
thing is I don't want you guys have any
levels of full of [ __ ] in you because
you will win I genuinely think that it's
not bad thus I'm trying to make you feel
comfortable to be okay I go around and
say I'm gonna buy the New York Jets if
somebody who cares about money the least
out of every [ __ ] I'm the one with the
biggest like I'm gonna buy this but you
know it's an issue where I'm going yeah
but you guys know I'm better cuz you can
see how I act do you understand
just keep it in mind yeah go over there
all right we have that person that I
have to go right cool